I think everybody struggles with mental
illness in some form REO winter has
never shied away from talking about her
struggles with anxiety I think there's a
huge stigma around it and I don't
believe in that at all I think it's
absolutely ridiculous and also there's a
huge misconception that people can only
getting that like people who have money
or fame or do this like people don't
struggle with anxiety and and it's it's
kind of pointless and now she's opening
up about improving in her mental health
and she's addressing her recent weight
loss the Modern Family star is known to
clap back at body shamers but when fans
asks her why so thin during an Instagram
Q&A she revealed the change in her body
is actually due to a change in her
antidepressants quote I couldn't lose
weight no matter what I did the change
in medication instantly made me drop all
the weight I couldn't lose before by
just giving me back a metabolism the 21
year old also admitted that while she
has lost weight she actually wants to
gain a few pounds of muscle and get
healthier adding she wants her back that
infamous but yes yes I also love that
she always claps back like response to
people and whiring about this kind of
stuff exact like that honesty that I
loved
exactly shutting it down and when
another fan inquired about Arielle's
current mental health state she said she
has been quote doing pretty good but at
mitts quote it's a journey and she
credits her six years of therapy for
helping noting she doesn't know where
she'd be without it something we also
talked to her about last year I think
everybody should be able to share their
story and and have a voice to do it and
go through it together and and make it
kind of like a community because I feel
like people need to understand that
everybody has anxiety or has depression
or has something and it's not a person
being broken or having to focus it's
just like how have you been able to
handle it like what's the key for you um
it mainly it's you know you try and
center yourself in reality and then you
talk to people that love you and you
there are tons of different methods for
people you know I go to therapy and I
think therapy is great some people don't
believe in therapy some people think
therapy is
like only four broken people it's not
therapies for everyone it's awesome
Arielle has also been open about the
hardships of Fame
but in her Q&A she says she's grateful
for her platform one day you did
something great and then the next day
you're like plastered as a thousand
other things it's it's a really
difficult industry I mean we're blessed
to be in it I'm gonna be able to make
content that we love and that other
people love but it's also an industry
that it is true it builds you up and it
can tear you down just as fast soon
though Arielle will be saying goodbye to
Modern Family I'm so sad about it she
does tell fans though she's looking
forward to her next chapter I can't wait
to see what Arielle does next and see
how they wrap up everything on modern
night know what's gonna happen with Alex
for all the latest in entertainment news
make sure you guys are subscribed to all
things e team I'm Katie Krauss and I'm
Courtney teza know bye for now guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]